thank you sick for those generous
introductions the polluters highest
honor this year went to a story that
many Floridians had suspected all along
that off-duty police officers are the
worst speeders on the road until the Sun
Sentinel followed the digital footprint
left by speeding cops the evidence had
been largely purely anecdotal but the
reporters got the records that proved
clear that provided clear an impeachable
proof that off-duty policemen were
racing at high speeds through tall
weighs endangering not only themselves
but also other motorists the key to
unlocking this story were highway toll
records in the course of a three-month
investigation reporter sallykaus teen
and database specialist John Maine's
mind son pasto records from twelve South
Florida police agencies they found
nearly 800 cops who reached speeds of 90
to 130 miles per hour in the previous
year many of them driving while off duty
very search showed that speeding cops
had costs at least 320 crashes since
2004 killing or maiming 21 people the
victims included a 14 year old girl in a
college student yet Sun Sentinel's
investigation revealed that only one
speeding cop went to jail and only for
60 days we're going to show you a video
that explains the seriousness of the
problem and it's tragic consequences we
expect police officers and deputies to
come rushing during emergencies but what
about when there's no emergency South
Florida law enforcement officers are
sworn to uphold traffic laws on our
roadways but they're among the worst
speeding offenders a Sun Sentinel
investigation has found oftentimes the
speeding ends with fatal results this
was a tragic accident I know what I did
was wrong i know i was driving faster
than the speed limit on that night the
Sun Sentinel has learned that more than
700 cops from a dozen age
sees hit speeds of 90 to 130 miles an
hour through South Florida highways from
October of 2010 through November of 2011
Miami police officers were among the
most chronic off-duty speeders with 143
cops driving at least 90 miles an hour
all of them outside city limits more
than 50 exceeded 100 miles an hour when
shown the records even Miami police
officials seemed surprised by the
numbers the sun-sentinel uncovered can I
get a copy of this cuz yeah we're going
to lose beautiful beautiful thank you
with all those arms yeah Wow it's not
very prudent to be up violating the very
laws that we reinforce this is something
for our internal affairs major to
receive and investigate because you know
again the policy is what the policy is
in the policy says they will they will
adhere to the laws rules and regulations
and the Department of orders and you
know anytime we find that someone's not
doing that and they'll have to deal with
the consequences that come with that the
problem with speeding cops caught
national attention in October when a
state trooper clocked Miami police
officer fausto lopez going 120 miles an
hour on Florida's Turnpike on his way to
a second job
reporting this story was not easy state
tour operators initially refused to
provide the data they ultimately
released 1.1 million tollway
transactions using these records as well
as other creative methods that we'll
talk about shortly Sally and John
created an interactive database of 800
speeding cops and all the trips that
they they took where they exceeded the
speed limit the series generated
overwhelming reader response and set a
record for online page views some
readers even submitted their own videos
of speeding policemen the series also
produced immediate results 163 officers
have since been disciplined 1 Miami cop
was fired 10 others were suspended some
changes were systemic police departments
began monitoring officers driving
officers driving using GPS and other
devices another department was the same
methods employed by the sun-sentinel
they checked the officers toll records
best of all South Florida cops have
since slowed down in a follow-up story
the sun-sentinel examined a new set of
toll records and found an eighty-four
percent drop in excessive speeding as
one reader wrote to the paper thank you
for making the road safer and forcing
these guys to slow down Sally we have
200 students here who are about to start
working on their masters projects and
they are looking for story ideas where
did the idea for this story come from
the officer at the very end of that
video the one who saw nothing wrong with
driving 120 miles an hour in pre rush
hour traffic by the way simply because
he was running late to his second job as
a private security guard he was the
impetus for our investigation the
trooper the state trooper who pulled him
over and that was a by the way very
unusual occurrence in Florida they would
give a pass essentially to any law
enforcement officers as soon as they
recognized the vehicle but she didn't
she had seen this guy flying up
down the highway before and she pulled
him over she chased him for seven
minutes with her lights on before he
finally pulled over and her dashboard
camera caught the whole thing and you
see that you see him just zipping in and
out of five lanes of traffic she's going
you know over a hundred she can't quite
catch him and the video of that traffic
stop went viral and as you might imagine
and the stories in South Florida about
it just drew hundreds of comments most
of them you know people outraged that
the hypocrisy of police officers who
including him who write speeding tickets
for a living so blatantly disregarding
the law that they enforce so John and I
were both on the investigations team and
we actually had for a couple years
before that we had gone through some
staff cuts and we we weren't really
doing the long-term investigations that
we had once done and we got a new editor
and he was very interested and committed
to doing investigative journalism and we
just happened to be looking for ideas
right at that time so I went to John and
said you know we know this guy is not
the only cop out there doing this
because we've seen it ourselves and you
know this here's the perfect opportunity
to try to tackle this and then the
question just became well how we can
improve it so this this was one case
right and and and many of our stories
start with one case or several cases we
start with anecdotes but how do you
prove how do you go beyond the anecdote
how do you report a story that goes
beyond individual cases to show that
there's really a pattern of wrongdoing
well we we needed to have some kind of a
solid base of evidence and we had
discussions about whether what we had to
have something very good and strong and
we talked about Sally and I had talked
about how how are we going to prove this
and and one of the things we first
thought about was GPS we'll get the GPS
from the police departments that didn't
work the police departments either
surprisingly didn't
have GPS or they just told us forget it
you can't have it because you'll
identify where our cops lived and some
of them are undercover officers you
can't have it so eventually we came
across the thought well there was one
embarrassing thing we did was we went
out and bought a radar gun and and don't
ever try that it doesn't work we were in
an overpass at five o'clock in the
morning trying to shoot down at these
cars and it's dark and you can't see
anything you can't see if it's a cop car
or not what you can see in the
background is a big cloud of rain coming
right at you and we hadn't brought our
raincoats our umbrellas so we finally
got we finally got decided that the idea
what we had to do was get the sunpass
records these toll-like easy pass here
same exact thing and so we went out and
we requested the records at first the
agency said no you can't have them
because it's private information we
looked at the law and they said you
can't have the law says you can't have
personal and confidential information
released there was not none of that
these transponders were that the cop
cars carry which take a reading whenever
they go through a gantry were public
they were belong to a public agency
public agencies so that's where we went
out from there so did you have to fight
a lawsuit to get those records or you
just know we already did it ourselves we
didn't even have to get our attorneys
involved we just as kind of a standard
practice whenever we're we hit a
roadblock on records we say well show us
the the specific statute that you think
allows you to withhold this information
and they sent it to us and we looked at
it and it clearly it was the law that is
intended to protect your credit card
information when you you know give him
credit cards to pay for your tolls and
we just wrote back you know very very
short response actually but said you
know this has nothing to do with what
we're requesting and they after about
three or four days said yeah you know
you're right and they said it is a
public record we've never been asked for
this before but it's public and
unbeknownst to us at the time we were
actually still getting some resistance
within sunpass we learned this later
because I started getting anonymous
emails from someone who signed them just
the owl and it was clearly somebody
within sunpass who wanted us to kind of
figured out why we wanted these records
and and was eager to to help and one of
his first emails was you know I'm happy
to help you but you know you can't
reveal who i am and and i just wrote
back and I said I I don't even know who
you are and that works got a little
dialogue going and we found out from
this this source that there was there
was a new director at the toll agency we
never actually talked to her but this is
what we were told later who would come
from New Jersey and wasn't very media
friendly and was not too keen on the
idea of giving us this data and there
was some meeting coming up that she had
called with their general counsel
presumably to try to block the release
of it and this helpful employee had
enough clout there that he actually
instructed a subordinate to go into the
office on a weekend and download or
upload the data to an ftp site for us to
access so the owl was very helpful he
only lasted about a month and then flew
the coop and we never heard from him
again but but the tollway data didn't
tell the entire story right because they
just showed the time the police car
entered the tollway and the time it left
you had to audience actually you know it
only told you that it went through a
gantry not not the time that it left
only said that this cop car went and you
used the transponder number you want to
show that okay so there it is that's
what it looks that's exactly the raw
data we got for city of Miami and if you
look at it it doesn't show when they
started when they entered how and mostly
it doesn't tell you what the distance
was and that that was in computer work
you want to have everything
in rows and columns and have a nice neat
here's where you started on your trip to
work and here's where you got out you
went through the gantry to go but this
doesn't do it for you and also what it
doesn't do is doesn't have mileage so
right away we knew we had a problem we
call it called the state and said can
you give us the mileage between these
toll gantries and they said well we can
give you the mileage mile marker which
just just mile marker 13 mile marker 18
we knew that wasn't good enough because
this information we had to have it very
very accurate so after wondering how to
do that for a little while we we call
garments alley called Garmin the GPS
manufacturer and garment said we've got
just the thing for you it's a little
thing about the size of a matchbox and
it's extremely accurate it's runners and
bicyclists use it for for timing
themselves and so we got that one
hundred forty dollars in something like
that and and and so that's we set out to
drive ultimately ended up like 2,500
miles that we drove going gantry to
gantry in the dead of night and and
collecting all this data for mileage so
then once we had that it was simple math
really how long did that take you just
two of you collecting for each country
the mileage record it turned out to be a
lot more time-consuming than we
initially envisioned partly because it
was impossible to not get run over by
another aggressive South Florida driver
and do it yourself because you had to
slow down enough to mark the exact spot
underneath the toll Gendry and it was
too much to do for one person so it was
a two-person job one person drove and
the other one would mark the the
beginning of the route in the end of the
route with the GPS and record the
mileage so that ate up a lot of time and
it took us probably about six weeks I
guess we at one point recruited an
editorial assistant and the newsroom to
be our driver the other thing we
realized was it wasn't good enough to
just go one direction from one
booth to the next you could not assume
it was the same distance in the opposite
direction and a lot of that had to do
with exit ramps you know you might enter
with a just a straight shot onto the
highway or you might go through a loop
and that really affects the distance so
we had to measure each way both ways and
it was we got reimbursed for I think
2,500 miles on driven on our cars so
finding the evidence of the speeding was
one part of the story the other part was
finding evidence of the damage to
speeding it costs how did you go about
doing that Oh Sally is great about every
time she does a story she won't say okay
we've proved wrong doing but who are the
victims who are the victims here and and
so what she basically set out to do was
basically find out people who had been
killed by cops going at high rates of
speed and it happens to turns out that
there's quite a few of them and not only
that but sometimes the cops kill
themselves how did you find these people
who say a combination of just searching
actually google searching for certain
ones around florida that had had gotten
media coverage but we you know wanted to
do something more comprehensive than
that and for years john and our data
folks had collected florida highway
safety motor vehicle crash records so we
had all but about i think the last two
years worth so we ordered those from the
state and then we were able to just
search i think we ended up searching
about 1.7 million crashes looking for
any that involved police officers and
when those vehicles were cited for or
when excessive speed was a factor so
that's how we were able to find the 320
and then the deaths and the
you know the it really just helped
convey the the danger that this posed
and and the just tragic consequences so
one of the most immersive things about
these stories is your database you built
a searchable database can you show us
how you went from this to the actual
database um basically there's a I won't
go into the details but there was
problems with actually do building the
data to get the accurate readings
because this thing the way we had to put
to get data together we got many many
false readings and we basically it
bloomed up from 1 million 24 million
records and that's it there was nothing
we could do about that we just had to
figure out a way to fix it so that we
got really true and accurate numbers and
and that's that's what it looks like in
the end and you can see now the plaza
one plaza to that's a start and stop and
then the distance and then the speed
calculation so you had a million 4
million records like it ended up for
basically when I say false reading sort
of like a house of mirrors when you go
in and there's all these mirrors which
is the real person which is the real
number that that's how it ballooned up
to 4 million and and this is how it
looks like on the website this this
actually this is something we always do
these days this is a searchable database
that the user can use it's really no
good for me for my analysis i'm using
microsoft access and sequel server for
those that you know that in excel but
this we always want to build something
that people can go to our website and
play with basically and so this is that
where you could plug in a police station
agency or a county or even though you
could type in a transponder number and
the site got a lot of traffic and we
think it was probably cops looking at
their fellow
because the transponder doesn't actually
identify the cup right no and and one
thing we wanted we initially thought
we'd get the names of all the cops that
proved too difficult really we got we
knew one speeder the guy that started
the whole project we were able to
identify him pretty quickly but we when
we went to the agencies and started
saying can you give us all the all the
names who's got that transponder we were
running into too much difficulty and it
really in the end it really didn't
matter we really had the one guy and so
it wasn't worth spending more months
just trying to ensuing to get that data
okay your turn to ask questions we have
microphones on this side of the aisles
so please come up right just say your
name quickly and my name is Roger Miller
and I was wondering if you've seen other
news agencies try to repeat your study
using the same techniques how you feel
about them we thought we yeah we have
been contacted by a few I know in
Florida sunpass now is not releasing the
data or they were giving other reporters
problems with it and and we live in a
state with great public access public
records laws so you know I think that
would be an obstacle for for reporters
in other states you know might not be
able to get the data at all but I think
it's a wonderful idea anybody that can
I'm certain this problem is happening in
a lot of communities it's not just a
uniquely South Florida problem so I
think any other kinds of stories would
be great hi my name is Daniel dieppa how
many clicks did your database really had
because you hadn't the names of the
didn't have the names of the cops how
much interested that kind of generate
the web page that you're looking from
the database yeah the I can't remember
the raw numbers about how
lunch how many hits we got but we got
lots you know over time thousands of
hits which for the New York Times isn't
a lot they counted by the millions but
for us it was a lot yes by two questions
one when you brought this information
police I guess we saw the video but was
that that seemed very positive was that
actually how they responded beyond the
video but to what did they do to
actually fix the problems you said there
was a follow-up article they had
actually the speeding had gone down
dramatically what was the solution yeah
we made a decision to take what we had
found to the police agencies really
earlier than we normally would an
investigation we went about a month
maybe five weeks in some cases and just
and we also made a decision to give them
the data because we really wanted to vet
this we wanted to know ahead of time if
they were going to raise any significant
challenges to it and we weren't exactly
sure what to expect when we went in but
it was surprising to us every single
Department open an internal affairs
investigation based on what we hand
delivered to them ahead of the
publication and they all took it very
seriously you know they it's a liability
for a police chief or police
administrators to have their guys out
there especially off-duty with no
legitimate reason to be speeding and
crash into somebody it's a liability so
they were you know they were very
receptive they did different things I
think the biggest change was cultural
it's not that they didn't know this was
happening before it's just we presented
such irrefutable evidence of it on such
a big scale that it just became
impossible for them to ignore anymore
and I really saw a change know before
where somebody would call and report a
cop for going 100 miles an hour they'd
say you know bad cop and maybe write up
something in their personnel file and
that was it and they started taking it
seriously 11 department actually
modified a feature in the GPS in their
police cars so that this annoying
computer voice a woman's voice now comes
whenever they expedia limit exceed the
speed limit and she says you are
speeding so I'm sure they're very
thankful to us or that they should have
used your voice probably yes bhai my
name is Jenny I guess I'm just still a
little unclear so you've uncovered all
this data and then you take it to the
police departments and the Highway
Patrol but what was the step that you
were able to verify the number of these
cases weren't actually in route to an
actual emergency and what was the
percentage of those findings we we
couldn't say definitively the way we
characterized it in the story was over
half of all of those speeding incidents
occurred outside the jurisdiction of the
agency where the officer was working so
and they were you know pretty clear
patterns it was somebody kind of going
back and forth the same route day in day
out so it appeared it was people
commuting going back and forth the work
they weren't in their city limits so
they really didn't have a justifiable
reason to be going those speeds there
were certain countywide agencies and the
Florida Highway Patrol where we couldn't
tell because their jurisdictions are
much larger and we did we didn't say one
way or the other if that was off-duty we
just said many of them appear or most of
them appear to be off duty because
they're outside their cities and then
when the internal affairs investigations
came back after we had had published it
they did verify that that they were off
duty yes hi I was curious at what point
in the reporting process you knew that
this was a big story because it
obviously took a lot of time and effort
to nail it down and second I was curious
about your decision to go to Garmin were
there any concerns and going to a
private company with their scoop and
what you're trying to find a second
question first the the reason we went to
Garmin was we had we actually tried
driving it just in measuring distances
with our odometers and that's what we
were originally going to going to go
with and we went out in my car a couple
of times and then we went out in John's
car once and we happen to measure this
name one we got a different answer and
then we realize the odometers just
aren't as precise as we need them to be
because we had certain toll booths that
were only you know a couple of miles
apart or even less than that so if
you're off by a tenth of a mile that
really affects the speed so then we went
to an engineer and we said this is our
problem you know what would you do and
they said well GPS is is the way to go
you know that's going to get you the
kind of precision and accuracy that you
need so then it just became you know not
I didn't have any concerns about the
private company we just wanted to know
what would be the best model to achieve
what we were trying to and I'm sorry
what was your first question well our
heart Eureka moment we had a few of
those probably you know we we started
calculating the speeds we didn't wait
until we had measured everything you
know we did it at we would come back
after a day of driving around and John
would plug a few of those distances in
and we started with the ones that the
routes that were the most traveled so
we'd get you know the biggest volume the
biggest bang for our buck and we started
plugging the distances in and you know
we started seeing speeds a lot of speeds
like this over we made a decision later
on using 90 as a cut-off but we were
seeing you know many many more in the
high 80s but then we were seeing 90s and
100 and we thought yeah we're you know
we're definitely on to something here
this would have to be our last question
yes hi my name is Thomas I have a
two-part question they're both based on
data one is when you were calculating
the speeds from sort of one toll plaza
to another did you take into account the
deceleration and acceleration that would
have to happen and because that would
actually bring the whole speed down and
also for the Miami Police Department
whenever they were mentioned it always
was mentioned that it was always outside
of sort of miami city boundaries whereas
for other departments it was often
outside so what was the distinction
there why would the Miami cops always
outside on the first question yeah we
calculated average
speed and so if somebody was going 90
miles an hour and they got a average
speed was 90 and they got off on an exit
they were going even faster most of the
trip and what was the second question
the second question was yummy yeah the
reason was because the all of the toll
roads that the Miami cops were we're
writing on they were all outside the
city limits so if you if you had any
toll transactions for the city of Miami
they were automatically outside the city
some of the other departments they were
mostly outside the city but they may
have come into the city for you know
some of the the time and so you know we
couldn't say a hundred percent with
certainty that that those were off duty
so that's why we phrase it that way
there just weren't any toll plazas that
we included in within the city limits of
Miami very blatant speeding there thank
you for your questions we'll have more
time at the end of all three and also
sweet panels to to ask more questions